la question est la suivante je suis au
pot enfin je ne suis pas au pot mais je
me mets à la place de peau et je me dis
je vous sortent plein de nouveaux
smartphones je vous sors notamment celui
là là ça c'est le finepix trois pros le
finepix trois pros c'est le très haut de
gamme et je me dis bah tiens je vais
sortir également le feu y x 3 neo qui va
être du haut de gamme et je veux sortir
en même temps et bien le fun ii x3 light
qui est un milieu de gamme je sors donc
trois nouveaux modèles sur cette gamme
finepix 3 ok génial pie x 3 3 modèles sa
marque hummer suis là j'en ai déjà parlé
c'est leproux alors le prouva seul mètre
de côté on l'a déjà vu si vous n'avez
pas vu mon tel invite à aller voir ma
vidéo présente bien évidemment en bas ou
vie si je sais pas quelque part of our a
fait la vidéo est quelque part donc
assez intéressant on va se concentrer là
dessus parce que la question est comment
est ce que au pot va venir faire ses
choix stratégiques pour différencier les
deux modèles soyons clairs sur le
finepix trois pros on est à plumieux
euros la réponse est là les choses sont
claires
ok mais sur ces deux modèles là et bien
c'est un peu moins clair c'est un peu
moins évidente sur le fan dx3 neo
je suis à 7 199 90 pour venir je suis à
800 euros même si psychologiquement je
suis en dessous 7 199 90 et sur le light
je suis à 450 euros d'une différence de
prix entre ces deux modèles de 350 euros
donc qu'est-ce que pau est venu faire
comme choix pour différencier ces deux
modèles pour avoir une vraie différence
de 350 euros c'est pas rien c'est quand
même énorme et on reste dans la gamme
finepix on va donc regarder quelle est
la différence entre le phénix trois lots
le finepix 3 lite on va regarder qu'un
modèle est fait pour vous est-ce qu'ils
sont intéressants quels sont les points
forts quelles sont les faiblesses aux
lilas maintenant
[Musique]
ah j'aime bien ces vidéos qui commence
comme ça pas fonds table de partout on
jette les choses ça s'envole c'est
familial alors le finepix trois pros
laisse de côté parce que pour l'instant
on n'a pas besoin on l'a déjà vu on l'a
déjà testé est vachement bien avec la
caméra micro scope premier smartphone au
monde avec une canne et d'un microscope
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu d'ailleurs
dicle mon commentaire est ce que vous
l'avez déjà regardé ce smartphone est ce
qu'il ya pu vous intéresser moi je pense
assez what the fuck franchement la
caméra micro score alors regardez on a
ici les deux boîtes et on a surtout ici
au plat les deux smartphones convient
les différencier réellement niveau du
dos alors ici on m'envoyait la même
finition qui s'appelle l'opo glow l'opo
glos c'est un espèce de reflets regarder
on a l'impression que son palais m en
fait sont exactement les mêmes ça vienne
la cool de la lumière pardon ce qui fait
que ça va vous donner un peu toutes les
couleurs de l'arc en ciel qui vont
passer devant alors la différence on la
voit surtout ici au niveau du design au
niveau des caméras là ces néo on le voit
que petit module qui est singulière plus
rond sur le light on voit qu'on a le
même nombre de capteurs dans les deux
cas vous êtes sûr coloro s ont ce point
basé sur l'android on recollerait cette
journée déjà parallèle vous a fait une
vidéo dessus
c'est une super expérience sur android
ensuite parce que ça ne s'arrête pas là
au niveau des similitudes
on va retrouver d'un côté et de l'autre
exactement la même techno de charges
alors là vous le voyez vous avez un bloc
de charge de 65 watts
ces deux-là superbook 2.0 donc ça va
extrêmement vite c'est de la recharge
basse tension sur le nez haut à gauche
ici vous avez un écran de 6,55 pouces
tandis que sur le light vous à l'écran
de 6 à 24 pouces
dans les deux cas vous avez un écran
amoled full hd + un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 hier un taux
d'échantillonnage tactile de 180 m
c'est sensiblement la même chose le
poids est quasiment identique 195 g
contre 179 m
franchement ça se tient le neo est un
poil plus grands on a une finition qui
est différente le nez ou vous êtes avec
un côté plus plat là on est plus incurvé
alors quelles sont les différences et
bien les différences il y en a un peu
plus qu'on pourrait le croire on s'en
doutera déjà au niveau des batteries sur
le neo vous avez en fait deux batteries
tac
vous êtes sur chacune de 1250
milliampères pour un total de 4500
milliampères heures ça c'est les eaux
tandis que sur le light vous êtes à 2150
milliampères heure de chaque côté pour
un total de 4300 millan perreur vous
l'avez déjà calculé vous êtes gourmand
bravo et félicitations après il ya une
autre différence et on y vient si vous
n'avez pas les mêmes processeurs à
l'intérieur autant sur le pro vous avez
un dragon 888 qui aujourd'hui le
processeur le plus performant du marché
sur neo c'est un peu différent vous avez
le processeur le plus performant du
marché de 2020 de l'année dernière c'est
le snapdragon 865 5g à la différence du
light où vous êtes sur une version
différente c'est une autre série on
n'est pas sur la série 8 de qualcomm on
est sur la série 7
je vous en ai déjà parlé de ce
processeur c'est le sma dragon 7 165 g
on va avoir une différence de
performance mais quand même sur le light
on reste dans le haut du panier on reste
dans les processeurs les plus
performants donc en termes de
performance vous êtes tranquille ici
vous avez 12 giga de ram plus 256 giga
de stockage sur le light vous avez 8
gigas de ram et vous avez 128 giga de
stockage non extensible dans les deux
cas donc on voit qu'on ait une
différence de performance et on à 350
euros d'écart un moment il faut bien
tenir la charge et quelques passes 30
150 euros d'écart les techno drame sont
exactement les mêmes ces deux-là et
pédiatrique sont en alu fs trois points
ici sur le nez aux hôtes en alu fs 2.1
sur le light qui ira un peu moins vite
en lecture et en écriture
voilà une fois de plus on vient chercher
ses 350 euros quelque part cette petite
différence de prix ce fait là sur le neo
on a du wifi 6 sur le light du wifi 5
rien 9 points qui est assez intéressant
par contre un peu plus conséquent c'est
au niveau des l'expérience audio alors
je vous fait écouter sur le neo vous
avez des hauts parleurs stéréos celui-là
est celui-là l'autre par ailleurs que
vous avez ici là sur la droite
c'est vraiment un petit haut parleur
confort qui vient rajouter mais ça reste
quand même assez médium on n'a pas la
même expérience de stéréoscopie j'en ai
déjà parlé bon voilà c'est pas parfait
c'est pas idéal c'est comme ça mais
malgré tout on a des haut parleurs
stéréo ici par contre on le voit on a
absolument aucune prise jack nulle part
ok sauf que sur le light et bien on
retrouve une prise jack ça c'est
intéressant parce que les présidents
on y retrouve surtout dans le centre et
milieu de gamme et ici comme on l'est
sur un smartphone milieu de gamme et
bien au pot a dit on va bien mettre la
prise jack pourquoi parce qu'on a plus
de place à l'intérieur donc on vient la
lettre et dans son segment de prix ça
marche bien que là pour le coup vous
n'avez absolument aucun haut parleurs
stéréo haut parleur mono
le son est quand même beaucoup moins
fort on a moins de volume un cas une
différence au niveau du bluetooth
bluetooth 5.2 pour le lait au bluetooth
5 points pour le light mais là là où il
ya une grosse grosse grosse grosse
grosse grosse grosse grosse grosse
différence est là où on vient vraiment
comprendre ce fameux delta des 350 euros
oui je leur fais une fois de plus parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre ça 350 euros
c'est sur la photo ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que le neo
il hérite du pro plus plus plus plus
plus le light c'est tout autre chose ici
en fait vous avez le même capteur de 50
méga pixels qui est co-développé avec
sony pour oppose spécialement ses
lit-et-mixe 766 tour f 1.8 stabilisation
optique sédation électronique avec un
autofocus omnidirectionnelle vous
retrouve également le même téléobjectif
saint 13 mégapixels
tu ouvres f 2.4 stabilisation
électronique et là je vous cache pas
qu'avec un tel objectif s'il ya pas de
stabilisation franchement ce fait mal ce
qui va changer par rapport aux pros est
bien celle ultra grand-angle qui va pas
être le même
ici on est sur un 16 mégapixels et une
caméra de sony c'est liam x 480 pour f
2.2 stabilisation électronique
et puis vous avez ici planck est juste
là c'est de la macro 2 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4 bon lui il est là histoire
2 mais beau vous connaissez mon point de
vue sur la macro je préfère qu'on veut
le faire avec un très bon
ultra-grand-angle qu'ils fassent macro
clown est une petite caméra de 2
mégapixels qui fasse de la macro on
regarde le résultat dans quelques
instants tandis qu'en face à la
justice'' sur le light et bien c'est
plus du tout la même chose mais alors
plus du tout et on va regarder les
résultats en photo dans quelques
instants
alors regardez juste en haut si c'est
votre grand
là pour le coup vous avez une caméra de
64 mégapixels on n'est pas du tout sur
le capteur co-développé avec sony on est
vraiment ailleurs on est sur une
ouverture de f 1 point cette
stabilisation électronique uniquement
par stabilisation optique on se retrouve
juste ici avec un ultra grand angle
ici pas de 16 mégapixels comme sur le
neo on est sur un 8 mégapixels
on ouvre à f 2.2 en dessous on a de la
macro 2 mégapixels f 2.4 c'est la même
chose
et là vous allez retrouver un capteur
portrait noir et blanc
ouais ce qui est la même chose et ça
c'est très intéressant et bien c'est ce
qu'on va retrouver au niveau de la
caméra de celle fille parce que oui ici
que vous soyez sur leproux que vous
soyez sur neo que vous soyez sur le
light vous avez une caméra de prendre 2
mégapixels tour f 2.4 c'est la sony mx
615 avec une stabilisation électronique
donc s'il ya bien un truc qu'on retrouve
partout sur la gamme et bien c'est bien
cette caméra de ses filles et puis le
logo pau le logo peau il est partout
c'est normal c'est la marque alors quand
je regarde la première photo j'ai
tendance à me dire que sur le light est
bien gardé mon ciel est un peu plus
bleue ma façade est un peu plus clair
que de l'autre côté mais ce que je vois
également et ce qui m'intéresse est bien
c'est que là j'ai un truc est plus
naturelle sur la gauche et vous allez le
voir un peu plus loin la même chose ici
mon ciel va être beaucoup plus éclatant
sur le light bas face à beaucoup plus
claire tandis que de l'autre côté et
bien j'aurai plus ces ombres et j'aurai
un côté un poil plus naturel quand même
c'est un peu moins poussif
je viens continuer si je me rapproche
fait les mêmes observations au niveau du
bâtiment et au niveau du ciel je vois
qu'ici déjà sur le light et bien jacques
huppert beaucoup de bruit je récupère du
bruit ici ici mais nuage j'ai
l'impression que c'est un espèce de pop
art
tellement que c'est poussif au niveau du
bruit tandis que l'autre côté ça doit
bien alors c'est normal parce que là je
suis effectivement sur mon capteurs
principalement 64 mégapixels et que
forcément mais à force de venir vous met
dedans ça marche moins bien je me
rapproche au max bon c'est pas dingue
dingue mais malgré tout sur le neo c'est
mieux que sur le light vous le voyez
notamment sur le tag rouge ici ou sur le
light ça paraît un petit peu réac
alouettes il ya un grand duc est plus
naturelle sur la gauche sur le nez ou
que sur le light à droite et on va venir
le voir un petit peu plus loin je passe
sur l' ultra grand angle
j'ai des bleus qui sont beaucoup plus
soutenue sur neo que sur le live tout de
suite vous
moi je vous récupère du bruit
indirectement quand je me rapproche
d'avantagé tout une beaucoup plus de mal
sur le sur le light on voit que la lgo
est un peu plus poussive pour essayer de
proposer une image qui conviennent alors
que de l'autre côté comme je t'ai
l'objectif ça marche bien et lorsque je
le pousse au max aïe aïe aïe ça fait mal
on fait la même chose ici on regarde
bien les nuages c'est vraiment ce qui
m'intéresse ce ciel qui tout de suite
bon là d'un côté de l'autre ça
conviendra comme ça l'ultra grand temps
que ça va dans une vraie différence de
colorimétrie elles sont ultra
grand-angle on est tout de suite sur un
bleu d'une vraie cohérence nouvelles sur
le neo entre le capteur principal et
l'ultra grand angle on est sur les mêmes
bleus au niveau du ciel on est sur la
même colorimétrie sanabia tandis que de
l'autre côté et bien c'est pas ça on
vient se rapprocher ok ok ok j'ai déjà
du bruit sur le light et là tout de
suite à dire un peu plus compliqué pour
le live quand je lui beaucoup plus loin
et lorsque je me rapproche au max ou
suite voyait assez difficile c'est très
difficile mais c'est normal alors caméra
de cellfish passe rapidement mais c'est
la même chose donc on oublie on continue
ici sur le neo est sur les talons
regarder ça c'est marrant parce que
j'étais dans une zone que j'étais un peu
plus à l'ombre et julien photographes et
des choses plus au soleil on voit que
c'est un poil possible pour ni
reconstituer la maison derrière j'ai
l'impression que sur le light c'est
quand même pas trop trop mal au niveau
de l'arbre sur la gauche mais j'ai plus
de détails sur mon arbre sur ici là sur
le sur le neo sur la photo de gauche que
sur le light sur ma photo de droite je
suis un peu plus jaune
ici j'ai quand même plus de détails j'ai
mon ciel qui va être plus pêchus ici sur
le neo que sur le light on continue on
passe sur l' ultra grand angle bien ça
va être sensiblement les mêmes les mêmes
critiques je viens me rapprocher je vois
que j'ai un peu plus de mal sur le ciel
ici sur le neo que sur le light là pour
le coup bondues âge est cramé tandis que
de l'autre côté il ne l'est pas ça
s'intéressent envoyé cette différence ma
photo m plus jaune ici sur le live que
sur neo donc là je me dirai que light et
bien qu'on pense pas trop mal je viens
me rapprocher et bien avant tout de
suite sur le light et ben il a du mal et
on le voit sur la brique là il est
possible de chez poussif et lorsque je
viens au mcs bon ben voilà on oublie et
c'est là que ça devient vraiment
intéressant que c'est très révélateur
regarder la mondeo à gauche j'ai en ciel
qui est bien on voit bien le bleu
on voit bien les arbres devant la sur le
light l'algo va venir a cherché à
compenser ce qu'il a du mal à faire donc
l'âge d'un ciel qu'il est plus bleu
c'est le même moment c'est vraiment
photographié à 5,5 10 secondes
d'intervalle eh bien je vois que mon
ciel devient tout blanc
je vois que mon verre et bien sûr les
arbres devient un peu vert jaunâtre on a
complètement perdu tous à la plage
dynamique on lui a dit au revoir on
vient effectivement compensé au niveau
des petits arbustes par rapport aux néo
l'autre côté mais c'est pas beau enfin
le rendu n'est plus naturelle on a tout
perdu les couleurs sont peu du tout
naturelle et on est sur une scène qui
n'a plus rien à voir
je passe sur le très grand temps que
c'est la même chose le ciel les plus
bleu les couleurs sont très pâle c'est
pas beau du tout je viens me rapprocher
je conserve de la qualité sont montés au
sur live je suis complètement perdue et
lorsque je commence à jouer davantage et
bien la lgo compense sa marche pas et
lorsque je joue au maximum voilà ça
marche pas mais ça c'est normal et la
même chose sur cette scène la regarder
j'ai bien mon ciel bleu sur le neo sur
le light jet en ciel qui est bleu pâle
je perds quand même au niveau de mon de
montvert qui plus mais bon c'est pas les
mêmes capteurs mais c'est vraiment ce ce
côté traitement voir comment est ce
qu'ils arrivent à s'en sortir dans des
scènes comme ça la regarde et là j'ai un
ciel qui est plus qui qui marchent plus
l'ag des nuages qui sont cramés de
l'autre côté sur les os ça marche bien
je viens ou mais je suis toujours
beaucoup mieux ici sur mon nez au que
sur mon lit qu'en fait ce que je vois
globalement c'est qu'on est au jir mieux
la plage dynamique
lorsque je suis en plein soleil et que
je prends des choses en plein soleil le
light s'en sort pas trop mal mais dès
que je viens de positionner à lons et
que je joue des chansons en plein soleil
à la salle bien poussif et c'est plus
dur pour lui quand même 350 euros
d'écart et on y retrouve vraiment essayé
d'aller dans le détail c'est par
ailleurs dans push et ça doit tout de
suite beaucoup plus difficile sur la
macro c'est la même chose le light a
beaucoup plus de mal que le néo c'est
pareil là je retrouve plus de détails
effectivement ici son nom néo que sur
moonlight sur la photo nuit c'est aussi
très très très intéressant là je voulais
juste me un éclairage bleu de cotone
éclairage indirect est bien le néo
forcément s'en sort beaucoup mieux le
capte beaucoup plus de lumière forcément
14,50 mégapixels mangera beaucoup mieux
ces risques sur le light
eh bien voyez c'est plus tarder on y
arrive - c'est normal on n'a pas le même
capteur et captera moins de lumière et
ça marchera moins bien regarder à gauche
on a le nez au ce quand même pas trop
mal on voit bien les détails on voit
bien que la chaise bleue est beaucoup
plus bleu au niveau du derrière ici que
l'on récupère du bruit en photo c'est
clair et c'est sans appel
le champion c'est le finepix 3d olefins
dx3 light s'en sortira bien dans des
conditions de bonne luminosité mais il
faut pas non plus trop lui en demander
si pour vous de 800 euros ça reste
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et qu'on dit
j'ai pas mettre 800 euros sur smartphone
et que les 450 euros franchement ça vous
fait de l'oeil et si votre usage
principal est bien celle gaming vous
allez sur le light à 350 euros d'écart
vous assurez vous serez pas déçus mais
par contre là dessus la photo 1 s'est un
peu moins ça si pour vous la photo c'est
extrêmement important et vous voulez
quelque chose qui se rapproche
réellement de la réalité eh bien on va
venir ici on va venir mettre un peu plus
d'argent parce que la différence elle se
fait vraiment là dessus au niveau des
capteurs le fait d'avoir le même capteur
que le finepix trois pros et bien ça se
paye ça se paye c'est sûr on n'ira pas
aussi loin que phonique trois pros
attendait c'est normal 800 euros va pas
tout avoir non plus mais par contre je
puis vous assurer que si vous voulez un
smartphone extrêmement performant
endurant expérience logiciel top très
très très bon en photo mais voulait pas
non plus prendre un smartphone à plus de
1000 euros le néo il est donc voilà la
grosse différence se fait surtout au
niveau de la photo
donc la question laquelle il faut que
vous vous puissiez répondre est ce que
vous voulez un smartphone qui fasse des
photos fidèle à la réalité
neo ou est-ce que vous acceptez quelques
petits compromis qui à côté de ça vous
voulez une machine extrêmement
performante et sans concession light et
si vous pouvez vous le permettre
le pro est vraiment magnifique voilà moi
j'étais vraiment intéressés de faire ça
parce que ces deux smartphones j'ai
trouvé intéressant et je me suis
vraiment posé la question alors je
connais la fiche technique 1 mais la
fiche technique ce n'est pas suffisant
il faut laisser guèye fall et sur le
terrain je me suis dit 350 euros nom de
zeus et quand même beaucoup d'argent il
ya un delta qui est énorme mais ce rôle
ingrat doigt comme ça on dit bon ok et
puis vous assurer que derrière ces 350
euros d'écart ils sont vraiment là elles
sont vraiment là au niveau de la photo
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire pas anodin trouve
très vite pour continuer à parler d' eau
provient évidemment de smartphones de
photos d'amour et tout ça des bisous de
l'amour à bientôt ciao